[Musique]
fils d'une lignée de jardinier du roi
André Le Nôtre n’est à Paris le 12 mars
1613 en 1637 le roi Louis XII lui
garantit la survivance de la charge de
son père et il deviendra premier
jardinier du roi Louis XIV de 1645 à
1700 soit durant plus de 50 ans André Le
Nôtre a été le premier jardinier à nobli
par un roi jardinier oui mais pour
élaguer des dénivelés taillés des allées
majestueuses planté des partères d'eau
dans l'axe des perspectives ou créer des
fontaines au détour d'un bosquet
le nôtre c'est du land art avant le land
art il impose des angles de vue tout en
laissant déambuler avec beaucoup de
liberté tout a l'air droit
orthogonal de niveau et pourtant rien ne
lève vraiment
[Musique]
le nôtre a été l'auteur des plans de
nombreux jardins à la française en
France et à l'étranger il a eu notamment
pour tâche de concevoir l'aménagement
des parcs et des jardins du château de
Chantilly de Saint-Germain-en-Laye et
bien sûr de Versailles mais son premier
chef-d'oeuvre sera pour le 13 en vogue
ministre des Finances du roi Louis XIV
Nicolas Fouquet en 756 de notre dessine
les nouveaux jardins de son nouveau
château de Vaux-le-Vicomte ces plans
sordonnent autour d'une perspective
génialement maîtrisée en composant la
mise en scène du château dans l'espace
de 40 hectares taillés au cœur de la
nature André Le Nôtre réalise une
parfaite harmonie entre architectures et
paysages la force de son dessin
d'ensemble et Sa Majesté théâtrale
l'abondance de l'eau et des surprises
font du jardin de veau l’œuvre
fondatrice de l'art des jardins à la
française ici André Le Nôtre travaille
en étroite coordination avec lui le veau
et Charles Lebrun architecte et le
décorateur du château réalisant par
terre plan d'eau bosquet et un
renversement de perspective
à vous Fouquet leur a fourni une page
blanche où l'architecte le vaut et le
paysagiste le nôtre ont pu travailler
ensemble pour réaliser un ensemble
harmonieux
et pour preuve du travail commun entre
l'architecte et les jardiniers je peux
vous citer deux techniques qui
utilisaient ensemble
contribue à réaliser ce fameux ensemble
harmonieux
la première technique et la technique
architecturale dite de la transparence
qui nécessite qu'aucun mur ne vienne
arrêter le regard alors c'est pour
mettre cette technique en œuvre qu'au
17e siècle sur ces trois arches du
château il n'y avait ni porte ni gris ni
fenêtre les trois arches transperçaient
donc le château de part en part le
rendant comme transparent et si on
restitue cette transparence lorsque l'on
arrive par le nord du château on
découvre dans la même vision le bâtiment
et au travers les jardins et l'ensemble
est si bien réalisé qu'il est très
difficile de dire de l'autre côté là où
s'arrête le château et là où commence
les jardins
dans les jardins on a utilisé la seconde
technique qui est la technique de la
perspective ralentie qui consiste à
agrandir encore une fois tous les
éléments du jardin par terre statut
bassin taupière au fur et à mesure qu'il
s'éloigne du château
ceci afin de modifier la perception
visuelle que l'on a de la perspective
naturelle et d'arriver à englober un
grand jardin tout autour du château dans
un ensemble harmonieux
les perspectives raccourcis ou
accélérées les rocailles les partères de
buis les canaux les grottes bosquet et
bassin étaient déjà scénographié dans
les jardins italiens mais André Le Nôtre
porte à la perfection les schémas de
composition des jardins antérieurs à son
époque il introduit des procédés
empruntés aux mathématiques et à
l'optiques qu'il va déformer au gré des
sites rencontrés
réduites au traits les plus simples son
œuvre servira de référence absolue
imitée à travers toute l'Europe
[Musique]
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est quand
le nôtre arrive en 1656 il y a l'époque
une rivière qui passe en diagonale au
sud du château et le premier travail
d'André Le Nôtre et de faire détourner
cette rivière et de la canaliser de
façon à ce qu'elle passe sous terre à
l'est déjà jardins après quoi il fait
combler ce qui est donc devenu l'ancien
lit de la rivière pour disposer d'un
terrain plat où il va pouvoir composer
les jardins alors il va le faire de
manière innovante puisqu'à l'époque
l'usage héritier du moyen-âge et de
disposer quatre par terre égaux qui vont
s'organiser autour d'un bassin central
avant le nôtre va disposer des
partenaires rectangulaires très allongés
et une allée centrale qui va servir
d'axe de perspective ce que nous avons
sous les yeux et qui en quelque sorte
incarne les jardins à la française
si d'ici on regarde le bassin rond qui
est au milieu des jardins et le bassin
carré qui est en arrière-plan on a
l'impression qu'ils font à peu près la
même taille alors qu'en réalité le
bassin carré et 8 fois plus grand que le
bassin rond puisque le rond mesure 470
mètres carrés et le carré 3800 mètres
carrés et ceci est vraiment
caractéristique des jardins d'André Le
Nôtre ou en permanence l'apparence
triomphe sur la réalité
ceci étant dit on va revenir à ce que
nous avons sous les yeux c'est à dire au
jardin de Vaud et au jardin la française
qui ne se résume pas à ce qu'on voit
c'est Hassan se résume pas à des parters
géométriques et symétriques c'est
beaucoup plus complexe et surtout ça
révèle la façon de voir le monde qu'ils
avaient à l'époque par exemple le
premier principe des jardins françaises
et de montrer que l'homme a dominé la
nature et peut la composer à sa guise
c'est dans ce but qu'on va utiliser des
végétaux persistants tu as une manière
rigoureuse ainsi que des matières
minérales pour colorer le fond des par
terre
ceci permet de s'affranchir à du rythme
des saisons en offrant un décor
quasiment identique tout au long de
l'année ça c'est pour le premier
principe et le deuxième grand principe
et l'alliance des jardins et du bâtiment
vous ne devez plus avoir un château
entouré de jardin mais un ensemble
harmonieux et pour arriver à ce résultat
le nôtre va disposer tous les éléments
du jardin les partaires les statues les
bassins de façon à ce qu'il s'intègrent
à la demeure comme autant de pièces
supplémentaires
[Musique]
alors en fait je peux expliquer pourquoi
on appelle ce type de jardin la
française c'est tout simplement parce
qu'ils ont été développés par les
jardiniers paysagistes français du 16ème
et 17e siècle le plus illustre de ces
jardiniers et celui qui a élevé le
jardin au rangard et bien sûr André Le
Nôtre
mais je dis bien développer et non pas
inventé car l'histoire des jardins est
une suite d'évolution où chaque page est
écrite en fonction de la précédente et
les jardins la française ne dérochent
pas à cette règle puisqu'ils sont
hérités des jardins italiens du 15e et
16e siècle qui eux-mêmes étaient inspiré
des jardins de l'Antiquité où les
alignements de végétaux les statues les
topiaires et les bassins existaient déjà
[Musique]
les visiteurs un peu ont un préjugé en
disant un jardin français c'est un peu
un peu triste un peu classique c'est
certes très beau très très équilibré
mais c'est là où le nôtre est un génie
parce qu'en fait ça paraît comme ça
assez simple mais dès qu'on se balade
dans le jardin français c'est là qu'on
découvre toutes les surprises qu'il a
voulu créer et la majorité des visiteurs
et on en discute souvent avec d'autres
châteaux que ce soit chantilly ou même
ou même Versailles 80% des visiteurs
s'arrêtent à la terrasse terrasse du
château et se disent bon j'ai vu j'ai
compris en fait ils ont vu mais ils ont
pas compris il faut aller il faut
marcher pour comprendre et donc au bout
de 100 mètres on a déjà des surprises
qui qui apparaissent au bout de 200
mètres il y en a d'autres il y en a il y
a des surprises dans un sens et des
surprises dans l'autre sens et ça qui
est intéressant et ensuite c'est
vraiment lorsqu'on a fait l'effort
d'atteindre le bout du jardin qu'on a
fait là on découvre le canal qui
n'apparaît pas qui n'est pas visible
depuis château donc ça c'est encore une
énième surprise qui apparaît juste au
dernier moment là on se dit il faut
faire le coup il faut faire l'effort de
faire le contour du canal pour arriver
au niveau de la statue bascule d'où là
on a une vue superbe sur les sur le
jardin et sur le château et c'est là
qu'on devine et qu'on comprend vraiment
la parfaite réussite de ces trois de ces
trois génies c'est l'équilibre parfait
et c'est vraiment un lieu magique
d'aller là-bas mais l'équilibre parfait
entre le jardin le château et même les
communs les communs qui servent d'elle
du château c'est à dire que si Fouquet
n'avait pas demandé à nouveau de
construire ou si le veau n'est pas
imaginé des des communs sur les côtés du
château le château serait presque trop
seul au centre de ce jardin et essayer
vraiment une réussite parfaite
[Musique]
pour défier les limites de l'horizon le
nôtre déploie un génie de la projection
qui n'appartient qu'à lui dans
l'enchaînement des vues et des figures
géométriques il crée une ampleur
nouvelle une grande dynamique
harmonieuse dans les rapports entre
l'ombre et la lumière les pures et le
touffu le grandiose et l'intimes le
proche et le lointain
[Musique]
la statue monumentale en plomb doré
haute de 7 mètres qui constitue le point
de vue final de la très longue
perspective constitue une allusion
allégorique au très puissant ministre
donc nous sommes maintenant au pied de
la statue d'Hercule Hercule est
représenté lorsqu'il vient de faire son
onzième travail mais ce qui est surtout
intéressant c'est de voir la perspective
que l'on a sur les jardins
et de s'apercevoir qu'en fait on a une
vision très différente encore une fois
une vue très différente de toutes les
vues qu'on a eu jusqu'ici lorsqu'on est
là on a l'impression que les deux
communs comme un ouest et comme un est
les deux corps de bâtiment latéraux sont
situés sur le même plan que le château
alors qu'en fait ils sont très en
retrait et de s'apercevoir une nouvelle
fois que des éléments sont cachés
d'autres éléments sont révélés par
exemple on a vu qu'on a un grand bassin
rond qui est le bassin de la gerbe
pourtant bien qu'elle ne soit située
qu'à 50 mètres on ne le voit pas
les broderies buides vue d'ici sont une
grande étendue verte dont on distingue
pas vraiment le dessin volontairement
les petits canaux sont une nouvelle fois
camouflée on ne voit pas les grilles
d'eau donc on se rend compte une
nouvelle fois que les jardins la
française qui ont un peu la réputation
d'être simple et un peu tout le temps
identique sont en fait très complexes et
change en permanence et ceci est du
principalement au savoir-faire d'André
Le Nôtre
[Musique]
nous sommes donc maintenant dans le
parterre de fleurs par terre de fleurs
créées spécialement à la demande de
Nicolas Fouquet puisque le nôtre lui
n'avait pas une grande adoration pour
les fleurs ça prend trop de temps c'est
trop éphémère et surtout ça vient
perturber la philosophie des jardins
françaises qui veut que l'homme domine
la nature mais Fouquet lui adorait les
fleurs il a demandé expressément à le
nôtre qui lui réalise un jardin de
fleurs proche du château de façon à ce
qu'il soit visible depuis les fenêtres
du château
et c'est ce que nous voyons là les
massifs floraux avaient Bénévent
évidemment disparu au cours du temps et
ils l'ont été recréés qu'en 2001
[Musique]
les jardins qui s'étendent à partir du
château se compose de terrasses et de
par terre et rien ne vient troubler sa
dominante horizontale les partenaires
les plus proches du château sont
considérés à l'époque de Fouquet comme
l'ornement le plus noble d'un jardin car
les plus visibles des appartements
[Musique]
à gauche du parterre de fleurs qui se
trouve excentrée se trouve le grand
parterre de broderie
à vous donc dans les boulins gras nous
avons des broderies de buis aussi nommés
turcurer car au 17e les motifs originaux
étaient inspirés par ce des tapis turc
qui était très en vogue à l'époque
[Musique]
donc derrière moi les partaires de la
couronne avec en son côté le plus à
l'est le grand bassin de la couronne
dans laquelle prend place une couronne
située ici en hommage au roi puisque les
fenêtres de la chambre du roi dans
lequel Louis XIV n'a jamais dormi
d'ailleurs mais les fenêtres de la
chambre qui lui étaient destinées
donnaient sur ce parterre donc le fait
d'avoir une couronne au milieu du bassin
était un hommage envers Louis XIV
[Musique]
André Le Nôtre invente des paysages qui
se recomposent au fur et à mesure de la
promenade cette renaissance perpétuelle
paraît tellement fluide qu'il en a Boli
la conception mathématique d'où la
nécessité d'une solide formation
à ce titre l'aménagement d'un jardin et
son entretien mobilise un grand nombre
de techniques comme le terrassement
l'hydraulique la sylviculture
l'horticulture est bien sûr l'optique et
la géométrie le tout au service de
l'harmonie
[Musique]
le roi Louis XIV lorsqu'il a vu ce
chef-d'œuvre il n'a il n'a plus eu qu'à
piocher et qu'à reprendre ces trois
talents et leur dire bon bah maintenant
je vous donne encore plus de moyens et
faites moi quelque chose d'encore plus
grand et c'est comme ça
[Musique]
après l'arrestation de Fouquet en 1661
André Le Nôtre se met au service de
Louis XIV et s'attaque au chantier des
jardins du château de Versailles il en
dessine les plans et supervise leur
exécution
mais si le jardin de Versailles passe
pour le modèle universel du jardin dit à
la française et de l'art d'André Lenôtre
il n'en demeure pas moins une oeuvre
collective au Grand Siècle l'entreprise
le nôtre fonctionne comme une grosse
agence d'architecture d'aujourd'hui une
escouade de collaborateurs spécialisés
parcours l'Europe évalue les besoins des
clients montent des dossiers sur
lesquels il intervient depuis son
atelier impossible pour lui d'être
physiquement présent sur la centaine de
chantiers en cours
loin d'être le geste achevé d'un seul
artiste libéré de toute contrainte les
jardins d'André Le Nôtre sont le fruit
pragmatique du travail en commun de très
nombreux intervenants
c'est le nôtre qui est le grand
personnage de cette mise en forme des
jardins avec en réalité le développement
de la formule du jardin la française
c'est pas le nôtre qui a inventé le
jardin à la française le jardin français
à la française existe pratiquement 50
ans à Leno avant le nôtre mais le nom de
va ici le porter à Versailles à une
échelle qu'une échelle considérable
autour d'un grand axe donc le grand axe
est-ouest qui fait 12 km de long donc il
part des collines de Meudon jusqu'à à
Villepreux de l'autre côté donc il va
d'un horizon à l'autre et à partir de ce
grand axe va s'organiser d'un côté vers
l'est tout ce qui est l'aménagement de
la ville avec les trois allées dont les
tracés sont dû à Le Nôtre l'écran la
barrière du château qui fait la coupure
entre la ville et et le jardin qui est
de l'autre côté et donc toute cette
organisation qui se développe sur le
parterre d'eau le bassin de la tonne le
tapis vert et le Grand Canal
donc le note va tracer cette sorte de
grande colonne vertébrale et à partir de
là quadriller tout l'espace qui est vers
l'ouest par des réseaux d'aller
perpendiculaire ou d'aller rayonnante
qui viennent donc structurer géométriser
tous ces Vespa on a souvent dit que le
travail de l'autre de l'autre c'était de
plaquer une géométrie sur une géographie
et c'est exactement ça l'exercice qui
est qui est mis en oeuvre ici c'est à
dire on incite qui est naturel vallonné
etc et l'autre va plaquer cette cette
grille
orthogonale cette grille géométrique sur
sur ce vallon d'Île-de-France à vrai
dire assez banal au départ le travail du
jardin la français c'est avant tout un
travail d'abord de terrassement
c'est-à-dire vous avez un site qui a un
site vallonné avec une pente et le rôle
du compositeur de jardin c'est d'arriver
à décomposer ce site en terrasse
horizontale terrasses en horizontale
avec des jeux de déblade remblais on
remblai avec les déblais de la partie
supérieure et on arrive à avoir un site
qui se découpe en gradins d'escalier et
dans chacun de ces gradins d'escalier on
implante un parterre on implante des
éléments de Fontaine et comme le château
lui-même est construit sur une butte on
a ce système de gradins en escalier à
mettre des trois côtés vers l'ouest mais
également vers le nord et vers le sud et
pour chacune de ces orientations le
nôtre va trouver une formule différente
avec toujours un effet où on avance
comme ça avec un contrebas un espace
qu'on ne voit pas et c'est seulement en
approchant de cet espace et en se
penchant au balcon qu'on découvre la
composition qui est faite en contrebasse
et ici on est côté sud et côté sud on ne
sait donc là où on a la meilleure
exposition et c'est de ce côté sud qu'on
va implanter une orangerie
[Musique]
il en existe dès la Renaissance en
France puisque même François 1er va
acheter en Italie mais il va également
acheter en Espagne un certain nombre
d'orangers pour mettre à Fontainebleau
et ensuite donc Louis XIV va rapatrier
un certain nombre de ses orangers de
Fontainebleau ici à l'Orangerie de
Versailles et pour abriter cette
collection d'orangers qui à l'époque
fait de comprendre 1000 arbres on va
d'abord construire une première range
orange celle qui est construite par le
veau qui correspond à peu près au quart
de l'Orangerie actuelle ensuite comme la
collection ne vient de plus en plus
importante que la composition des
jardins s'amplifie progressivement on va
détruire cette orangerie de l'euro qui
est construire la Grande Orangerie de
Mansart que vous voyez ici donc un
bâtiment ici avec des murs très très
épais ainsi une orangerie qui n'est pas
chauffée c'est à dire qu'en été on ouvre
toutes les fenêtres pour que la chaleur
pénètre à l'intérieur imprègne les murs
et après ce sont les murs qui par leur
masse par leur inertie accumulent la
chaleur de l'été et la restitue en hiver
au végétaux sachant que les grandes
fenêtres que vous voyez ici sont
elles-mêmes fermées par des menuiseries
qui comportaient à l'origine un
quadruple vitrage pour assurer une
isolation thermique et éviter les coups
de gel sur l'intérieur de la collection
à Versailles le nôtre peut fine ses
conception en matière de jardin des axes
principaux entrecoupés d'aller
secondaire délimitent les bosquets des
décors et des jeux d'eau originaux
contrastent avec la rigoureux symétrie
des masses boisées les triages et les
charmilles forment de vastes mûres de
verdure qui souligne les perspectives
les années principales sont jalonnées de
statues et les obliques mènent au
Bosquet afin de ménager la surprise
vous avez vu dans les grandes
perspectives on a ces murs végétaux qui
viennent saturer ces espaces de bosquets
et chacun des 15 bosquets de Versailles
à sa personnalité son style son
architecture ce sont des décors qui
associent des fontaines des statuts des
architectures de treyas parfois des
architectures de marbre mais chacun de
ces 15 bosquets vraiment une ambiance et
une configuration tout à fait différente
ici le bosquet des Trois Fontaines c'est
un bosquet très important dans la
création de Versailles c'est un des plus
beaux bosquets de Le Nôtre donc c'est
une composition complète créée par Le
Nôtre en 1675 et qui s'organise à
l'origine en trois terrasses et ces
trois terrasses vont être pourvues
chacune d'une fontaine et d'un bassin en
haut vous avez donc le bassin rond au
milieu le bassin carré et en bas le
bassin octogonale
donc là on est sur la terrasse haute
avec le bassin rond elle bassin roncier
le plus petit mais c'est celui qui a le
dispositif le plus hydraulique le plus
important avec ces deux couronnes le
couronne périphériques couronnes
centrale et 140 g donc la couronne
centrale monte plus haut la couronne
périphérique est plus basse et ce
dispositif donc de jet d'eau et cacher
dans ce décor de gros blocs de rocailles
et ces décors de Roca ils voulaient
retrouver ici mais à une plus petite
échelle alors on sait par les factures
de travaux que les rocailles qui
ornaissent ce bosquet venaient d'une
carrière du côté de Montfort-l'Amaury
c'est la mention qu'on a au 17e siècle
donc des matériaux qui sont des
matériaux par endroits rustique comme
par exemple aussi toutes les écailles de
roches de meulière de meulière que vous
avez en face avec quelques morceaux de
silex qui viennent de la région
parisienne et que l'on fait voisiner
avec ses bandeaux en marbre marbre du
Languedoc et qui viennent eux de la
carrière de cône-minervois dans l'Aude
et toute cette cascade s'organise ait
autour du motif central ce motif central
c'est la grande coquille et vous voyez
que pour parachever l'ensemble de ce
décor on a une ponctuation par des
coquillages alors qui sont des
coquillages exotiques qui viennent de
l'océan Indien et dont on a pu récupérer
quelques exemplaires pour remodeler donc
le bosquet des Trois Fontaines
donc là on est sur la terrasse centrale
donc ce qui correspond au bassin carré
et ce bassin carré fonctionne à partir
de ces deux grosses canalisations que
vous avez ici avec des jets d'eau qui
sont légèrement orientés c'est-à-dire
ceux-là sont verticaux aux angles et les
trois qui sont au milieu partant bien
pour amorcer un berceau d'eau donc comme
une espèce de voûte qui permet de voir
ici en transparence quand vous êtes au
milieu vous voyez sous cette goutte
d'eau vous voyez la fontaine axiale et
l'enfant nous sommes sur la troisième
terrasse donc le bassin octogonal avec
au centre ce qu'on appelle un buffet
d'eau c'est-à-dire un système de gradins
superposés l'eau sort par un geste
central et rebondit sur les gradins et
chacun de ces gradins et décoré donc
avec ces rocailles sémelières c'est
coquillages exotiques donc les roses
sont des strombes les rouges ce sont des
casques donc on a ici les des éléments
qui font allusion à un thème plutôt
maritime
[Musique]
pour sa vie privée le roi fut construit
le Grand Trianon à l'écart dans le parc
afin de se tenir un peu éloigné de la
foule bruyante des courtisans
dans les jardins la maîtrise de la
nature est totale dans ses dégradés de
verre
[Musique]
alors vous voyez derrière moi le bras
nord du Grand Canal paru généralement le
roi Louis XIV arrivait en bateau depuis
Versailles pour venir séjourner donc
dans son palais du Grand Trianon il
remontait donc la rampe du fer à cheval
et donc par les ardents il pouvait
accéder directement soit à sa chambre
qui était le lieu par lequel il dans
lequel il séjournait le plus
généralement soit également dans son
salon du Conseil c'est-à-dire le salon
des glaces et puis également vous voyez
l'ensemble du parterre haut du jardin
c'est ici que généralement on dressait
des temps de pendant les beaux jours
pour que le roi puisse dîner le soir
avec quelques dames de la cour qu'il
avait invité à Trianon
[Musique]
depuis 400 ans les jardiniers bien
traditionnellement au mois de mai
plantent-les par terre alors nous sommes
en train et bien d'agrémenter ces par
terre des fleurs qui étaient celles on
peut y aller à l'époque nous installons
donc des clés de marguerites toutes ces
plantes comme les asters et notre but
c'est de reproduire les parters à peu
près tels que ils étaient sous le 14
notre objectif finalement final serait
extraordinaire si demain matin le roi
Louis XIV revenait redécouvrait ces par
terre et apprécier nos fleurs comme il
appréciait celle de son jardinier le
nôtre
lieu des divertissements de la Cour du
roi Louis XIV puis capitale du royaume
et scène du pouvoir absolu Versailles
est un symbole de la culture française
du 17e siècle s'il était talentueux
André Le Nôtre n'en était pas moins un
fameux courtisan qui réussit à
s'acquérir les faveurs du roi sous une
bonne amie probablement travaillée qui
de son vivant lui value le nom de
bonhomme le nôtre il a su se placer à
l'écart des intrigues de la cour et
s'attirait les bonnes grâces d'un roi
passionné de jardin
[Musique]
durant sa carrière le paysagiste va
dessiner et réaliser de nombreux projets
en France et à l'étranger notamment pour
Charles de d'Angleterre en 1684 le nôtre
transforme pour le Grand Condé le cousin
préféré du roi de France les jardins ne
sont au château de Chantilly
son parc n’occupe que 115 hectares d'un
domaine qui en compte 8000 et qui sera
fortement marquée par les deux axes le
long desquels André Le Nôtre structurera
ses aménagements
[Musique]
chantilly et le seul jardin créé par le
jardinier de Versailles dont l'axe ne
passe pas par le château mais par son
esplanade
[Musique]
le nôtre a tracé une grande perspective
allant de la grille d'honneur et se
prolongeant de l'autre côté du grand
canal jusqu'en forêt
le domaine de Chantilly présente une
vaste réserve de nature et créative
comprenant forêt parc bois canaux et par
terre qui se déploie tout autour du
prestigieux palais
[Musique]
le château est là parce qu'elle a été
construit sur un rocher sur un chemin
stratégique entre la ville de 110 la
première capitale de France est bouvée
de l'autre
c'était un château contre les par des
familles qui pouvaient contre les taux
de trafic et passer sur cette route un
château médiévintaine qu'on se l'imagine
avec des fortifications des tours un peu
comme un château de la Belle au bois
dormant en quelque sorte après autant de
Louis XIV le château avec complètement
perdu sa fonction militaire en quelque
sorte parce que la France avait été
entièrement pacifié la France a envoyé
ses armées ailleurs mais il y avait
jamais d'armée par ici donc on n'avait
pas du tout plus du tout besoin d'un
château fort mais les châteaux
devenaient des endroits
des endroits d'apparat des endroits où
on s'amuser pour les princes
[Musique]
quelques autres particularités qui sont
marrantes à Chantilly c'est justement ce
grand axe d'habitude le nôtre faisait
toujours c'est par terre à partir d'un
château baroque ici c'est pas le cas on
a le grand axe sur lesquels nous sommes
ici dans le sens nord-sud et le château
est sur le côté c'est parce qu'à
l'époque le château n'était pas du tout
celui qu'on est actuellement en fait là
on est à la troisième version ou même la
cinquième si on compte les petits
châteaux forts qu'il n'y avait avant
à l'époque de notre il y avait toujours
le château fort médiéval le Château de
la Belle au bois dormant avec des
Tourettes dans tous les sens et d'un
autre qui adorait la symétrie et donc il
ne pouvait pas se permettre de faire
lire les sons
avec comme pièce maîtresse un château
vieux de plusieurs siècles à son époque
qu'il n'aimait pas du tout donc ce qu'il
a fait c'est qu'il a mis sur le côté et
il a créé ce grand axe au milieu avec la
Manche derrière une année qui s'est un
peu refermée au fil des anges
malheureusement mais qui continue encore
sur plusieurs kilomètres de part et
d'autre de l'autre côté il y a la grille
d'honneur qui est dans une dépression
parce qu'elle ferme le site mais comme
ça là il peut passer au dessus et de
l'autre côté il y a aussi une allée qui
continue pendant des kilomètres en cœur
sur sur cet axe qui a été créé par Le
Nôtre
[Musique]
on a un peu la vision absolue de Louis
XIV transposer à la nature c'est-à-dire
on a des lignes droites des angles
droits tout sauf tout ce qui est naturel
après est arrivé à la Révolution le
parterre un peu souffert et quand le duc
de mal est revenu il a essayé de
restaurer le partenaire
[Musique]
le parterre à la française de Chantilly
offre le point de vue le plus
éblouissant du jardin il comprend de
vastes miroirs d'eau reflétant le ciel
de nombreux jets d'eau et fontaines
ainsi qu'un programme statuaire de
grande qualité
de tous les jardins de Lenôtre chantilly
était le préféré de son créateur
[Musique]
et donc par terre le nôtre date de cette
époque aussi il a transformé le marécage
qui se trouvait ici en parterre alors à
l'époque le seigneur du château était le
grand connétable c'était un cousin de
Louis XIV c'était un peu la bataille
entre lui et le Louis XIV sur qui
pouvait avoir la plus grande plus beau
le plus magnifique et par terre alors ça
ils ont forcément gagné parce que Louis
XIV avait quand même un peu plus de
moyens que le prince du château de
Chantilly mais il y a quand même
quelques particularités de parterre de
nôtres qui font que c'était sa fierté la
première c'est les fontaines ça
s'appelait à l'époque les miracles des
autres au 17e siècle c'était extrêmement
impressionnant parce que c'était le seul
fontaine dans le monde à l'époque qui
pouvait fonctionner 24 heures sur 24 et
pour ce faire le nôtre avait dévié une
rivière pour les alimenter en continu à
Versailles par exemple ou par tout
ailleurs vous aviez des machines
hydrauliques assez impressionnantes qui
rem de l'eau vers une grande piscine et
qui se trouvait dans une partie haute de
la ville et quand Louis XIV baladait
dans le jardin vous aviez l'armée des
petits jardiniers qui couraient derrière
le roi qui ouvrait les vannes pour faire
fonctionner les fontaines quand le roi
rentré dans une salle X ou Y et quand il
partait il fermait les vents de nouveau
il corrien derrière le roi parce que
s'ils ouvrez tout il y avait après un
quart d'heure il y avait plus d'eau et
après il fallait que le bassin se
remplisse pendant 2 ou 3 semaines pour
que tout puisse fonctionner de nouveau
tandis qu'à chantilly la particularité
ici était justement qui avait un de
l'eau qui arrivait en continu
de tous les jardins d'André Le Nôtre les
jardins de Chantilly sont ceux qui
comprennent la plus grande étendue d'eau
totalisant une superficie de 25 hectares
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici on est au centre du parterre avec
les trois personnages principaux dans
les statues au milieu la place d'honneur
c'est le grand Condé
pendant son règne chantilly était un peu
était un endroit où était accueilli
souvent les personnes qui étaient pas
très respectueux du pouvoir dont Molière
qui est venu jouer des pièces ici qui
est venu écrire certains pièces de
théâtre ici et qui étaient pas toujours
en accord avec le avec le Louis XIV et
la troisième statue qui est là c'est
André Le Nôtre et quand la statue a été
restaurée il y a quelques années elle
était presque noir et assez dégradé on a
découvert que sur la feuille qu'il tient
dans la main il y a le plan du parterre
avec à côté de parterre et une autre
partie du jardin à la française qui
était derrière nous et qui a disparu
pendant la révolution qui a été
transformée en jardin en anglais après
[Musique]
le nôtre souhaitait qu'une bêche figure
sur son blason ce qui passe presque pour
un trait d'humour quand le cordo le
crayon l'équerre les instruments de
mesure optiques auraient eux étaient
plus appropriés sur ces armoiries car le
nôtre n'a probablement jamais retourné
une plate-bande mais bien des paysages
entiers
[Musique]
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est très bien
illustré dans les jardins du château
royal de Saint-Germain-en-Laye dans
l'Ouest parisien André Le Nôtre dessine
les jardins de Saint-Germain entre 1663
et 1672 son projet de perspective
l'ayant emporté sur celui de
l'architecte le veau ici le nôtre
ordonne château par terre allait forêt
et vallée en une composition irrégulière
et complexe
au fil des siècles sa grandeur reste
intacte notamment avec l'une des œuvres
majeures du jardinier la grande terrasse
Louis XIV voulant imprimer sa marque il
va demander à Lenôtre de créer deux
grands axes donc là qu'on a derrière
nous qui fait 3 km donc qui est face au
château vieux avec ses grands parters
réalisés à la demande de Louis XIV en
1663 par le nôtre et donc nous sommes
dans l'axe du château vieux avec ce que
l'on avait pas du tout l'aspect que l'on
en a actuellement avec avec ces plantes
très abouties des hybrides qui de façon
horticole sont sont très séduisantes on
avait ici essentiellement de la verdure
du buis
sans doute de la santoline de l'if voilà
du vert sur du verre avec du gazon mais
des motifs qui des dessins qui
reprenaient des arabesques et qui
reprenait en fait les dessins que l'on
avait pour représenter les pas de danse
parce que Louis XIV était l'un des plus
grands danseurs de son époque c'était
toujours dans la représentation et donc
bien quelqu'un de cette époque là voyant
c'est par terre là tout de suite ça lui
faisait penser à tel pas de danse et par
conséquent la référence à telle musique
ça ça a disparu puisque de nos jours
c'est très difficile à entretenir pas
suffisamment de personnes pas
suffisamment non plus compris ni
sollicité par le public les gens
préfèrent quelque chose un petit peu
comme ce que l'on a derrière qui est
davantage 19e voilà là ici on a quelque
chose de très joli très chauré avec des
dahlias avec certaines variétés
diplômées avec voilà des coloris
chatoyants moi je travaille toujours
avec le cercle chromatique et les gammes
de couleurs proposées et donc nous avons
sur les côtés qui nous maintient tout ça
Dubuis au centre de ces parters des
cônes difs qui respectent le nombre d'or
à savoir que l'on a donc un mètre de
circonférence à la base pour 2 mètres de
haut
ces cônes sont entretenues deux fois par
an selon des tailles au gabarit toujours
faites à la main dans les règles de
l'art comme ce que l'on fait sur le
château de Versailles et puis au centre
on a ce que l'on appelle un Boulingrin
Bolling green donc à jeu de boules sur
gazon c'était là où la cour se retrouver
pour jouer à la boule donc on a ces
pièces de gazon inclinées des
vertugadins qui retenait la boule dans
le jeu
le nôtre pour ces parters jouer sur des
nuances de vert mais aussi on avait des
couleurs en permanence donc voilà de la
chamotte rouge couleur brique on avait
du marbre blanc on avait votre marbre
careur de la houille ou de la crasse
noire de l'ardoise bleutée on arrivait à
voir en permanence des couleurs très
nuancées très contrastées avec ses
entrelats de buis qui reprenaient donc
les pattes danse voilà donc là ce sont
les grands parters le jardin régulier et
là je me trouve actuellement donc sous
ces rideau d'arbres qui sont entretenus
en forme de marquise parce que c'était
les endroits où les chevaux les
cavaliers passaient à l'ombre et où on
pouvait se promener à l'ombre une fois
de plus voilà il était mal venu que
d'être bronzé donc on avait eu ces
rideaux d'arbres ou des treillages comme
l'on peut encore en trouver à Compiègne
actuellement donc nous avons des
gabarits on un canon de dimensions de
mètres 20 souris d'eau 4 mètres pour le
rideau complet et donc il faut savoir
que le nôtre a fait sa formation au
cabinet dans le cabinet de Simon voulait
donc l'un des grands peintres de
l'époque le grand peintre de cours donc
c'est de l'architecture végétale il faut
se dire simplement c'est ce que l'on
verra tout à l'heure sur la grande
terrasse que on maîtrise le végétal
comme il comme s'il s'agissait
d'architecture on oublie qu'il s'agit de
plantes on domestique la nature c'est le
Roi Soleil il maîtrise son environnement
et tout son entourage
on va avoir des bassins avec des jeux
d'eau on va avoir les les grandes
calculs de perspective imaginez-vous une
perspective de 3 km avec des jeux
d'optique qui abusent l'oeil du visiteur
qui est qui lui font croire même
aujourd'hui que ces 3 km sont plus
courts et on vous invite à vous y
engager un peu à vous y perdre et à
regarder côtoyer toute la vallée de la
Seine et donc à avoir on le verra tout à
l'heure de l'autre côté de de Paris
donc là on se trouve sur l'autre
perspective du domaine national de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye à savoir celui qui
faisait face au Châteauneuf et donc on
est sur la réalisation magistrale de Le
Nôtre à Saint-Germain à savoir la grande
terrasse 1945 mètres 1945 m depuis
l'angle que l'on a ici jusqu'à
l'extrémité sinon sur la totalité petite
terrasse belvédère qui est ici et grande
terrasse 2500 mètres donc ça a été
achevé par Le Nôtre en 1674 et c'est
essentiellement à la demande donc
toujours de Louis XIV mais c'est suite
un débat entre le veau et puis le nôtre
ou faisant face au Châteauneuf il
fallait depuis ce belvédère avoir un axe
qui allait maîtriser le paysage vous
voyez on a toute la vallée de la Seine
on voit
[Musique]
une allée de chasse pour se rendre en
fait en forêt bénéficie du coteau
admirer la vue sur la vallée de la Seine
et donc se rendre en forêt pour aller
chasser mais aussi aller à un relais de
chasse ou se trouvait Madame de
Montespan
dont Louis XIV lui avait offert le
Château du Val et Louis XIV ça lui
permettait donc de se rendre auprès de
sa maîtresse qui qui résidait voilà donc
elle est aussi inclinée à savoir que
donc entre la balustrade qui a été créé
au 19e donc c'est vraiment un quai sous
le nôtre et Louis XIV la balustrade est
inquiet et donc vous avez 60 cm entre
les arbres plus encaissés que la
balustrade donc vous êtes vraiment là il
est légèrement incliné pour regarder
vers les lointains vers le paysage le
soleil levant le Roi Soleil
[Musique]
tous les soirs le roi empruntait donc
cette magnifique perspective pour
honorer son devoir conjugal
on arrive ici sur un octogone le rond
royal qui était donc complètement
minéral pas de gazon du gravier pas de
garde corps comme on a ici et un chemin
qui permettait donc d'accéder aux petits
châteaux du Val ou Louis XIV dans sa
jeunesse allait retrouver madame
mademoiselle de lavallière puis ensuite
Madame de Montespan donc c'était les
relais de chasse dont il était
propriétaire
qu'il avait en forêt de Saint-Germain
pour le nôtre et Louis XIV ça n'a jamais
été un jardin complètement fini mais qui
a servi de prototype pour toutes les
grandes réalisations
novatrices de Versailles c'est
Saint-Germain-en-Laye
[Musique]
on le voit des jardins qui racontent des
histoires et même l'histoire
ils sont le théâtre à une invitation au
savoir à l'imaginaire et au plaisir
plus tard Colbert le Premier ministre du
roi Louis XIV charge le nôtre d'embellir
le jardin des Tuileries qu'il transforme
en profondeur
[Musique]
il va ouvrir plusieurs perspectives dont
l'une servira de tracer à la future plus
belle avenue du monde l'avenue des
Champs-Élysées à Paris
à sa mort en 17
est très étroitement lié au Siècle d'Or
de la France et à son rayonnement
géopolitique
[Musique]
il restera certainement le seul
jardinier connu et reconnu dans le monde
entier
[Musique]